students actually do get kicked out for
putting a clause around Facebook for
example students do actually get found
of racial harassment without a hearing
for publicly reading a book
hi I'm Matt Welch editor-in-chief of
Reason magazine and I'm here today with
Greg lukien off and I pronounced that
pretty really badly who is the president
of the foundation for individual rights
in education I get rights fire fire fire
is celebrating its 10th anniversary this
year tell the kids back home exactly
what fire is done what was the genesis
behind it and what you have accomplished
this decade well fire defends basic
liberties on college campuses freedom of
speech most of all but also due process
religious liberty freedom Association
for example and before coming to fire
I'm a constitutional lawyer I had
absolutely no idea how bad it was I knew
it was a little bit bad on college
campuses I knew that political
correctness was a problem I didn't
understand that I'd suddenly go into
domain where students would actually be
learning these terrible lessons and in
some cases destroying in other cases
burning other students newspapers if
they didn't like their opinions over the
years we've actually it's were a
relatively small organization but I'll
and I was I think coming like the fifth
employee but over the years we've
actually been able to have victories at
150 colleges 150 victories at colleges
around the country and we've affected a
total of about two and a half million
students when you say the sort of speech
code thing came out of the sort of
political correctness of 1980s and 1990s
I guess many people might have thought
that we've gone beyond that what are
some broad categories of sort of
malfeasance that you see in universities
well definitely speech codes are
everywhere still and this is and the
reason of American we can be forgiven
for thinking that these were things of
the past because not only did were they
condemned in the early 90s not even the
president condemn them they lost every
single court challenge from nineteen
eighty nine to nineteen ninety-five is
just one after the other after the other
all lost in court so everybody said well
thank goodness that's over political
correctness and speech codes are over
seventy seven percent of colleges of
public colleges that are bound by the
First Amendment maintain laughably
unconstitutional codes and so far we've
been proven right in the courts there
have been 11 challenges to codes that
fire has deemed red light codes and
every single one of those codes one
hundred percent have either been
rescinded by the university or
are beaten in court and you don't really
have a hundred percent success rate in
litigation but meanwhile the speech
codes are bad enough because they're
teaching students that if you say the
wrong thing you can be punished and
that's a terrible lesson to be teaching
people or democracy there also again
again against the law but I feel like
the worst things that are happening is
that students are learning by example
which is even more powerful and we have
what we call our red alert schools there
are five schools across the country that
have so consistently and stubbornly
violated either student or faculty
members rights that we've actually we
take out an ad and US news & world
report's to basically say don't go to
these schools what's the next frontier
what's the greatest challenge that
you're working on right now it's a sort
of role this this this entrenched system
back well it we try to take every
possible approach I think the most
important thing is to get it get the
word out there that this stuff is really
happening and its students actually do
get kicked out for putting a clause
around Facebook for example students do
actually get found of racial harassment
without a hearing for publicly reading a
book professors do get in trouble for
using epithets in class in order to
criticize the epithet these things are
really amazing and when you hear them I
think there's a tendency for people who
don't have any idea that's going on to
go oh that's that's hyperbole but we
document all of these things on on our
website so the biggest thing that we
have to do is overcome at some amount of
a some idea that essentially sure maybe
there's a problem on college campuses
but it's no big deal it's a really big
deal and you'd be amazing the things you
can get in trouble for and they can find
that website at the fire org at the fire
org and speaking of which I hope you've
enjoyed this at the website of reason TV
for reason TV I am Matt Welch thank you
you